please welcome mr. Jon Favreau the
director I will start things off and
then turn it over to you guys mr.
Probert when you talk about why this
movie at this time like what convinced
you to go for it right now well a lot of
it was the enthusiasm of of Disney and
and specifically alan horne who's really
connected with this film with the story
as a from the Kipling stories when he
was growing up and I connected very much
with the with the animated film when I
was growing up and and so we had common
ground of both having great affection
for this property and the question
became if we love it so much in those
other forms why do I do it now
and and as he pointed out to me says
look he saw a life of Pi he realized
that the technology may have come to a
point where you can actually tell the
story in a different way and and maybe
bring some of what exists and existed in
his imagination when he was growing up
visually onto the big screen and I was
very compelled with the idea of of
taking what can be done in visual
effects now I was also very impressed
with films like Planet of the Apes
Avatar Life of Pi as well and and
specifically what was done in gravity
the way that they filmed the principal
photography as though almost as over an
element shoot for for an effects for an
effects piece and and it became a big
puzzle and and and after sleeping on
that and thinking about it I came up
with a with a take on it when I came
back and we all discussed it sound
sounded really really cool and so a
hundred years ago was the book
two years ago was the animated film and
now 50 years later it's time to update
the story for our for our generation the
actors I'm just wondering if you could
talk a little bit about how John
convinced you to come on board or sort
of what you loved most about jumping in
John sat next to me at a party it was he
he seated himself next to me with the
his benign smile and invited me to play
the gear and I think I said yes before
you got to the end of the CD we had met
we had met on the set of Ironman yogi
yeah and I was just I went from being
completely starstruck to being to being
impressed
until finally just feeling very a lot of
affection for him he's a sir Ben's a
incredibly generous warm wonderful
storyteller in person and being an actor
I got some whole days which I'm not used
to having and we spent some time
together in Miami we do I think I think
that the the captain in charge of the
project brings his or her tastes to the
project and I knew John well enough and
I'm fond enough of him to know that his
taste and judgment and his perception of
humanity and childhood and storytelling
completely concur with mine so it was a
joy to to join this beautiful project of
his
and you sort of how were you convinced
well well I I met with John while I was
I was very busy with the campaign for 12
years a slave at the time that I met
with John and he very quietly walked me
through his idea for this version of the
Jungle Book and what struck me was the
compassion with which he was talking
about these characters you know there
was all this state-of-the-art stuff he
was going to do with it but at the heart
of it was this the love of the story and
like a real a vision for each character
that he was going to bring to life and
for me that was what got me John and I
were working on John called me to do a
trailer for a game called destiny and
there was a little piece in the
beginning of that trailer that father
was reading to his son
the story of Mowgli from the book and so
we connected immediately in between
takes talking about the the book and the
material and I am a Kipling lover and
and and it went away and it wouldn't be
cool if one day this could be a realized
film and and then John is so as Sir Ben
said really in touch with all of his
experiences and and which is really
wonderful when you meet someone who is
that khane in that shark who has not
only the memory of it but has the actual
feeling for it and so we had this
wonderful conversation regarding it and
then months later he called me and said
hey guess what which excited me very
very deeply
just in my head remembered him reading
the the strength of the pack is the wolf
and the strength of the wolf is the pack
and and as we were developing the script
for jungle book that I was hired for
completely years later I think or a year
later I remembered him reading that when
we worked together and I said that's the
guy we need for akela who's the one
who's sort of passing the law down to
the next generation of wolves so it's
very weird how these things kind of it's
it's hard to imagine that there's not
some guiding force to the way all of
things that seemingly are exactly for me
it's synchronicities because for me this
story came from my mother my mother I
come from a divorced parents and I have
a brother so my mother would read this
law of the jungle to us realize it was
us three we had to survive it was the
three of us and so it really meant
something where he'd go up inside me
it's like why tell my four girls now you
never leave a bad behind that became the
theme as we develop the script that
became our theme and it all came from
just drawing back to the Kipling drawing
back to this experience hearing a
wonderful performance in my in my head
that I had heard and and then so it
organically evolved into that last
question for me before I turn over to
you guys
Neil if you could talk about how crazy
your auditions were oh and then sort of
those first meetings you all had I
understand mr. Favreau sort of had you
sort of work through things and if you
could just kind of talk about what that
was like starting to play around with
material it it felt like it was too easy
like that shouldn't have happened like
so easily I just auditioned once and
John really liked me and then the first
time I met um Sir Ben Kingsley and
Lapita I've voice recorded with Sir Ben
and I met you at UM d23 things we
mention and that was a lot of fun I got
to see like my face
and what about the sort of how you
orchestrated everyone meeting them
meeting each other well I tried to get
them to perform as much as I could
together because I didn't want I've done
animated voices before and and the it
tends to degrade eventually to okay just
say it again louder and and depending on
how good the filmmaker is either they
use the loudest take because there's the
most energy and makes the kids up in the
audience or they could weave together
the subtlety of a performance but it's a
lot to ask of people and I wanted this
to feel like a live action film and not
an animated film and part of the key was
to get a very conversational performance
and I know very much from being an actor
you rely upon your scene partner and the
energy of a scene partner that modulates
your energy and affects it because we're
a communal species we we we mirror each
other we key off each other there's
little status relationships going on and
scenes have to build and have a shape to
them and that comes from it's it's a
team sport you play it like a tennis
match with with the person you're you're
in front of the camera with luckily Neil
came with me whenever I went to
different locations or I think I think
sir Ben was the first person that Neil
worked with and of course he's a you
know a wonderful teacher and mentor and
experienced thespian and so passing good
habits on to the next generation which
works so well for the relationship
between the two of them on screen and
with Bill Murray as well and then to get
Bill Murray with Christopher Walken as
well so it's always trying to get combos
and making sure that I had reference or
capture data for the animators to work
from
I'm curious for the actors to talk about
surrendering theirs themselves their
personalities and some of their physical
features into the the characters they're
voicing and the relationship that an
actor now has with the kind of surreal
special effects that John has so
expertly created with his team for this
film so starting with maybe age before
beauty
Sir Ben would you like to address that
my secret to my performance I discovered
later which is odd but I had an
intuitive feeling grasp of something in
him and I realized much later that I
actually am playing Kipling the Bagheera
is Roger Kipling he's the voice of
Kipling in the story
my goodness Bagheera is Kipling so that
was that was although I didn't recognize
it sometimes an actor's intuition is
buried and you don't realize what what
you're mining as a source of energy
until perhaps afterwards but IIIi I'm
privileged to be the voice of Kipling a
man I greatly admire and loved and when
I was in the Boy Scouts our troop leader
no I was in the Cubs actually they
wishes before the Boy Scouts our troop
leaders called on kala well for me
reading the book as a child really made
a difference for me it made it allowed
me to dream and it allowed me to dream
big to have courage to have connection
for me I always wanted to be Mowgli as a
boy because there was a freedom within
that and a freedom to be able to express
myself the way I've always wanted to
I found that freedom through being an
actor and then seeing the movie really
did something else to my imagination it
allowed me to understand how we create
relationships with each other and how
those relationships are things that we
can really hold on to not much that's
material can we really hold on to
although we still like the
glossy things so for me to do this was a
and you used a beautiful word surrender
you know um I didn't know what John
would do in the room and but he is a
challenger and he challenges in a very
graceful way for you to do something
very different to have the the elements
that he saw in you to be able to do this
who you bocalee but then allows himself
to be courageous enough to ask you
questions so that you can play against
some of the things that you're used to
doing so for me in the room and having
John there with me
he always challenged me to play against
things and do things a little bit
differently to have strengths and not
just to be the loudest person speaking
and which then allowed me to see Raksha
to see Lapidus face and to create that
for myself in front of me when we were
having conversations so I really I'm
honored to be a part of this movie
because there's so many different
elements that go into making a film of
this nature or any film and it is I'm
just a channel or this particular
character that has to bring some love
compassion yet tough love to this young
boy this is my first voice over a role
and I I was attracted to it because
Raksha is like the eternal mother and
she chooses she chooses to take care of
this creature who is not one of her own
but as though he was and I remember I
did I I did a session a voiceover really
early on and then a few months later
John called me and again but this time
he had Neil's performance captured and
that really grounded the mother-son
relationship for me to see the
vulnerability of this boy and and the
love that he had for the wolf it only
made
for him grow even more and it's such a
beautiful image to see these two very
different creatures have this very real
bond I really loved all the Disney
references and the Yamada's to the
original film but I stayed through the
credits and I noticed at the very end it
says Fanta sound was the I was running
it's that just a joke that you guys
added or is Disney really calling
they're sound mixing Department mantas
on they're fans of sound Fanta sound
since it was going to be a concert film
Walt had a vision to put the audience in
the middle of the music and what would
be required and I think they only did it
in two theaters and I think they did
Carthay circle I did a theater in New
York they put speakers all around the
theater which cost a tremendous amount
of money even its day I think it was a
hundred thousand dollars to outfit a
theatre and they had to mic the the the
orchestra using a lot of isolated
microphones I think 30 microphones I
don't know the specifics I don't
remember them but but this was this was
essentially what the concept was and I
remember when I was talking to my sound
people and to my composer John Debney I
said wouldn't it be cool to explore what
fantasy would be now because it only
worked in two theaters and only for the
one film I think it was something he
thought you'd use in perpetuity but it
was something that was abandoned rather
quickly and the sound engineer said well
at most sound has that many speakers all
around the theater you use it for for
sound effects there's no reason you
couldn't use it for music and so I
talked to John Debney about he's a
Disney guy he grew up on the Disney lot
he knew Walt he you know he hung out
with the Sherman Brothers when he was a
little kid so he breathes Disney he
knows the culture and he really left at
the opportunity and so when we were
miking the the orchestra we isolated
instruments when we could and in the
sound mix Laura Hirshberg who's our
music music mixer we tasked her in the
at most mix with creating a fantasy mix
so if you go to see the film certainly
not most perhaps I'm not sure in 7-1 how
it works but specifically for Atmos you
will feel that they're instruments that
move around the theater
especially isolated instruments like the
flute as Mobley's running so now if you
ever see it in an Adobe cinema you'll
experience a version of what we were
trying to channel which was waltz vision
for this once again that is one of a
dozens of little opportunities we were
looking for to somehow tie back into the
legacy there were visual cues in the
film that you know as time goes on and
people get more familiar with it you'll
start to notice bits of Dumbo in there
looking at the monstro chase and
Pinocchio inspired some of the King
Louie stuff and certainly from Jungle
Book you'll see a lot of shots that are
pulled from one film into the next but
to me that's part of the fun of this
it's really just embracing the
opportunity and the emotional connection
that we have from growing up with these
with these films and seeing how much of
it we could you know just just need back
into the dough of the film and infantis
and was one thing I had wanted to do
just for a moment like this just to be
able to have an excuse to talk about
what what was going for and and for
people who are fans who appreciate that
we're trying to fulfill as they do with
the parks as the parks always change and
grow the movies should too
but I wanted to know if there was a
place that you went or someone you drew
from to get that across that maternal
instinct strong maternal instinct
perhaps her own mother or something like
that hmm I think yeah I think my mother
had a lot to do with my what inspired me
cuz I mean she's my example and and
she's a very good mother and yeah I ask
myself a lot of questions about what it
would be like to to to lose one of my
own though I'm not a mother myself but I
do love children when I was 12 I
preferred to stay indoors and babysit my
cousin's then then go outside and play
so there's that part of me that that is
very much alive I gravitate towards
children so yeah my mother definitely
was someone who inspired me question is
for the fathers up there in the movie
Mowgli essentially had three father
figures that all had very different
philosophies on life you know one of
them was just teaching them to to be a
leader one was teaching him to survive
individually and the other one is kind
of uh you know exploring his creative
side and letting him do what he wants so
personally like how do you guys raise
your kids which would you more associate
towards you know I think if you have if
you're blessed the children I think you
have to adapt each child in each moment
I'm not I I think you have to be very
pragmatic as a parent I think it's a lot
to do with the tension and and
responding to the to the ever-changing
complexities of a child's needs and to
address them moment by moment rather
than have a set book of rules that's my
two cents with ya I'm finding with my
four daughters that you know you first
learn as a parent when your child comes
out you want to form them and do all the
the the right things for them and then
you look at them one day and you go oh
they're already formed
at their own deal going and then that's
the moment for me that it clicked in
that their each very very different
there is the room for for the different
style of parenting and and and and
storytelling which is what's what are
the what are the traditions what are the
myths of a culture for their that
they're there to try to help the young
generation not have to learn lessons
painfully because you can learn them
through visualization and through story
and rule systems are our effort out of
love I think for to save the next
generation from the pain that the older
generation goes through to explain them
if the stove is hot without them having
to touch it and of course that's a
fantasy he can't protect they have to
learn on their own as well but that is
part of the strength of a culture is
that you can help at least give them a
context contextualize their struggles so
that as they persevere and come out the
other end they understand what it means
and it gives it purpose so although
there are three father figures and one
mother figure here it's really a
division a deconstruction of what
parents are they have elements of all of
them and just like Dorothy with her
friends going down the yellow brick road
they all represent different aspects of
what goes on in our and our brain I
think
and so as a parent sometimes I'm
Bagheera sometimes I'm blue sometimes
akela sometimes Raksha
I can handle offense because obviously
I'm sure there's a shortage of a short
stuntman though how did you handle those
scenes well I didn't I'm not a climber
that much because I was raised in the
city so I don't but after the movie it
looks like I'm climbing the lowest
climbing and it's like 400 feet off the
ground but I can only be 30 inches off
the ground so it's just a blue pad and
it looks like it's so like far down but
it's really not but he did but one of
the reasons we hired Neil and one of the
things he didn't he neglected to share
which was a big deal for us was we put
him through the paces with the stuntmen
before we hired him to see what type of
athlete he was and Neil's actually great
at a lot of sports but and so when I
would direct him sometimes it was more
like being a coach so sometimes he in a
scene he was you know his body posture
wasn't right and I'd say be more poised
to be a little more explosive and we
weren't getting there and I said do you
play baseball I guess I ever steal a
base he's like oh yeah I said pretend
you're getting ready to steal second
base so when you watch him running away
from the cattle in the Stampede that
wonderful posture he had he was stealing
bases I said ok go for ok big pitchers
looking at you ok go for it prayed for
it and so you get this incredible sense
of focus out of him and really that's
the trick of acting you do it to
yourself
depending on what technique you were
trained in it's tricking yourself into
believing that what you're doing is real
and creating an immediate moment
especially on film when you just need a
moment of clarity and once and and when
Neil's eyes would light up it would
light up the screen I knew I needed
someone to anchor emotionally the whole
story and so for you to subjectively see
it through the Issac and somebody who
even when he was not being busy as
somebody who's going to be compelling
and somebody you relate to and enjoy
watching for an hour and a half which is
a lot to ask of any actor and so it was
that it was Neil just the energy you see
who he is as John Carlos said they are
who they are even from a young age they
kind of inherit their soul
and and on top of that just being able
to be able to keep him engaged for
nine months we were working together to
keep that immediacy in that focus on q4
when we had to film so it was a big it's
a big deal what Neal was able to do and
I think a testament to all the people
not just the people on this couch who
worked with him but also the crew which
was really like a family can you kind of
speak to you've produced really large
movies and this is this is a really big
movie but such a unique one can you sort
of spell - I had the wonderful
experience of working for the last 20
plus years at Disney as an executive
overseeing production from that side of
things and and I transitioned from that
position to this film as a producer John
was very gracious to embrace me in that
role and that was also my only you know
most important job the biggest job I had
was to find I think the right filmmaker
and so we knew when Alan talked about
making his title and what we could do
with this title we all imagined what it
could be he started to figure out what
kind of skill sets you needed to pull
that off you need someone who had the
warmth and humanity to inject it with a
charm and with the thematic quality you
know you need he also had to have
someone who knew how to master this
incredibly complex thing because we knew
that there wasn't gonna be a live animal
on the set there couldn't be in fact you
know to portray the way Kipling had
imagined it had envisioned it if perhaps
even for the first time because he was
envisioning a live-action world with a
child living amongst these animals we
needed somebody could do all that and
when you look to the list it whittled
down to one guy and I'd known he was
available and then we call John know but
generally I worked to get a little bit
on some development of a very ambitious
idea before there was also a Disney
related and I knew that he knew these
things he was very uniquely situated and
knowing how to do all that and I'm
beyond that I also knew from the stuff
we'd worked on earlier of his deep
passion for for Disney itself and for
what it represented and he knew that as
well and I've been in the company for 27
years and he knew it as well as anyone
that I had worked with if not better and
so we were very lucky that he was
available your love for the story shows
in every frame so going into it what was
your biggest fear and now coming out of
it and having
come to the masses what are you most
proud of or most excited for people to
see my biggest thing was not to drop the
ball on the people for the people who
love this underlying property and
knowing inherently I couldn't just take
the g-rated musical for children and
make it photo real I knew we were gonna
have to deviate in some basic inherent
ways from that and could you still
preserve the soul and the charm and the
feeling of the first one while including
aspects from the Kipling stories and
changing from a g-rated musical to a
pg-rated adventure that would have more
thrills and be more exciting and scarier
at times than the original but also
maintain the heart the humor and and the
music - this is something that belonged
to the whole culture before we decided
to update it and so we you know so it's
very exciting and these are been a very
exciting couple of days as people are
seeing it for the first time and as
these thoughtful questions are coming
through as I sit in the rooms and talk
to each of you it's all starting to I'm
starting to get the sense of how how it
all came together and how we did so I
think we're very grateful to all of you
for taking the time to to ask these
thoughtful questions to take the time to
share the spread the word about it and
and also to the sense of relief as this
is all closing out and we could kind of
exhale and let let it know that our jobs
done and now it goes out to the world
you